the easiest place to learn 356 either in
modern or classic Styles is in fighting
ground which is a traditional street
fight experience this is where you'll
find familiar modes like arcade mode
online ranked and Casual matches and
offline versus modes this section's
shining feature however is this practice
area which houses some of the best
in-game tutorials the series has ever
had practice mode has the classic
freeform training mode fans expect but
it also holds full tutorials for the
game's core systems as well as character
guides and combo trials for all 18
characters on the roster these character
guides are a deep dive into what makes
each fight a tick as it explains not
only their special moves but also the
best situations in which to use them
fighting ground also lets you Tinker
with in-game commentators one of the
more balihood features of Street Fighter
6.
[Music]
oh no whiffs to drive it back while
hearing tasty Steve and WWE Zelena Vega
in an official Street Fighter game is
super cool the excitement those
commentators generate during an actual
tournament isn't ever captured here
those experiences are fueled by genuine
off-the-cuff reactions to the action on
the screen and in the arena while those
same voices sound like they're reading
situations from a script here which of
course is exactly what they are doing
Thrills to get around their defense if
you're looking for a less traditional
Street Fighter experience then what's
offered in fighting ground it's time to
take a world tour this is a massive
story mode with multiple chapters that
unfolds across the entire world the main
Hub is Metro city of final fight Fame
and it's stuffed with things to do and
references for long-time Capcom fighting
fans to find the rest of the mode is
broken up into smaller locations based
on stages from the core game these are
one of locales you'll visit sparingly so
they're not as big as Metro City but
they all still have a charm to them the
story being told in World Tour doesn't
live up to the standards set by fighting
games like Tekken 7 and more combat 11.
however everything happening around the
story makes up for in a big way walto is
essentially a street fighter RPG where
the fighting mechanics serve as the
battle system and it is very silly fun
walking through the streets of Metro
City I can challenge virtually anyone I
want to a fight be they a food truck
attendant an old lady going to the store
or a young Troublemaker getting up to no
good with every victory in my avatar
gains experience and levels up both
their core stats and the fighting styles
I'm using at the time this challenge
anyone mechanic is also technically
impressive as it really does let players
challenge anyone the game seamlessly
goes from challenging a passerby into a
fight and then returning to the free
realm without loading the stage is
whatever we were standing in front of at
that moment there is a noticeable dip in
frame rate when fighting in World Tour
and the visual quality of the stages and
random Fighters is nowhere near as good
looking as Ryu fighting Ken on a
carefully crafted stage but I didn't
focus on them much as I was too busy
enjoying the silliness of fighting every
Metro City Denizen that passed me by or
using money to buy a hat that somehow
improves my kicking power leveling up
fighting styles is the other major
customization option and growth path
your Avatar's move set is in your hands
and as you progress through the story of
Walter you meet the 18 masters of the
world aka the playable roster of Street
Fighter characters after earning their
respect through Mission completion or
even a one-on-one fight your avatar will
be enrolled as a student and given
access to that character's moveset
you'll pick a core move set for normals
but then you can pick and choose which
special moves you want your character to
use at one point my avatar used DJ's
rolling sold out Blanca's Blanca ball
chunley spinning bird kick and
kenshryukin that versatility and ability
to create your own fighter down to the
moveset is something new for the
franchise and a core part of what makes
World Tour fun using a fight stick to
control the Avatar in this mode is rough
the camera controls do not translate to
a controller with only one stick so
getting around the city can be
cumbersome the game does offer a
solution though it's not an elegant one
you can activate your fight stick as
Player 1 and your controller as player 2
and then switch between the two
depending on if you're moving around
Metro City or fighting someone while
this does mean extra space is needed for
two controls at once I appreciate the
convenience of easily switching every
time I want to use it your avatar also
takes center stage in the battle Hub
which is the final section of Street
Fighter 6's experience this is basically
a middle ground between World Tour and
fighting ground where players bring
their avatars into a massive Dome lined
with arcade cabinets you can sit down at
a cabinet and wait for a challenger
while training or you can join a queue
of players already seated the digital
equivalent of putting a quarter down on
a machine 356 netcode sings no matter
who I'm fighting or incredibly which
server I'm logged into I made sure to
log into the North America South America
and Asia servers during my review time
and nearly every match I played in all
three felt like my opponent was sitting
in the room next to me that's not to say
it's perfect as personal internet
connections are also a major factor in
performance but the Advent of rollback
netcode has been a major Boon to the
entire fighting game genre and 35 is the
latest beneficiary I had a couple of
matches in the North America region that
did have some netcode issues but my
online play experience as a whole has
been overwhelmingly positive fighting
games in the Modern Age live on through
their extra content and Street Fighter 6
is no exception Capcom has not only
confirmed the first four characters
coming via downloadable content but much
like 355 the game will feature its own
economy complete with multiple
currencies Drive tickets are earned in
game and fighter coins can be earned in
game or purchased separately as well as
this there's a battle pass which will
offer Avatar gear emotes and other perks
in both a free and premium track given
how strong the base game is having more
content and being able to play the game
in different ways is an exciting
prospect I can't get enough of three
fighter 6. it's been my last thought
when I go to bed and my first thought
when I wake up in the morning it has a
beautifully constructed fighting system
but also offers modes that take the game
very seriously and in other cases not
seriously at all there are some small
issues with performance in World Tour
but none of those are enough to derail
the overall package with the releases of
new Tekken and Mortal Kombat games it
very much feels like we're in a new
golden era for the fighting game genre
thankfully Street Fighter 6 steps into
the arena looking good and fighting fit
[Music]
I can't yeah
I am the advanced artificial
intelligence Leviathan
welcome to pikitola Island
[Music]
you've just hit credits on Resident Evil
4 and you're all set to put the game
down and move on to something else but
wait
there's a small itchy feel new game
pluses right there I bet hardcore would
be a ton of fun plus there's plenty of
guns to upgrade and Leon would look
really cute in those cat ears
follow this feeling
hello stranger and welcome to no HUD the
show all about finding new and
interesting ways to play your favorite
video games
today we're looking at Resident Evil 4
and why it's a huge mistake to stop
after your first playthrough that's
because Resident Evil 4 has so much more
to offer past a first time experience
I'm talking gameplay changes on higher
difficulties unlockables that offer fun
bonuses and a whole host of challenges
to pursue the game is a master class in
replayability with new layers to it with
each run and peeling them back reveals
one of the most highly replayable single
player experiences of all time
stranger
even during that first playthrough
Resident Evil 4 is already priming you
for your second man maybe even a third
it accomplishes this by not giving you
everything in a single playthrough and
in doing so lays down these seeds for
you to pick it up again you've likely
unlocked a bunch of challenges something
you might not really have paid attention
to but hey these seem doable and the
rewards are really cool looking and of
course in classic Resident Evil fashion
the game gives you a grade and a run
time at the end and uh oh uh a b rank
I get I guess that's pretty good but I
mean like you could shave down a few
hours you know a game is something
special when you're already planning
that next playthrough while still
working on the first what challenges
should I go for what weapon should I use
what charm should I accessorize with
most importantly what costume should I
wear cat ears
[Music]
not yet
foreign
now you can always start with a fresh
save but I think it is best to jump
right into New Game Plus on a higher
difficulty Resident Evil games have a
history of creative higher difficulties
that are more than just enemies you go
harder and the same is true for Resident
Evil 4. on Hardcore enemy variety and
placement is mixed up keeping you on
your toes puzzles are made more complex
and if you bump things up even further
too professional only perfect parries
work and there's no Auto saves the leap
from standard to hardcore alone is
substantial so much so that I wouldn't
recommend it as a first time experience
it can be rather painful if you aren't
prepared and yet it sings on New Game
Plus where you get to bring in a fully
Decked Out briefcase but don't get cocky
you cool jacket swoopy hair hunky you
sure you might suplex your way into a
new game plus on Hardcore with a fully
locked and loaded Arsenal letting you
blast through gonados like the badass
cool guy you are but as the game goes on
the difficulty ramps up and it still
proves to be quite the challenge
this all makes your second playthrough
feel just as fresh as the first now
you're truly starting to flex those
combat muscles you've been building up
all this time
[Music]
of course I made him it's not just about
the difficulty though Resident Evil 4
hits you with dozens of challenges that
can be attempted and completed during
many playthrough this is where things
start to get really interesting because
some of these force you to shake up your
playstyle most of the game's big set
pieces offer a unique alternate
challenge some are straightforward but
difficult like taking zero damage during
the minecart sequence others are a real
son of a like defeating Verdugo
without bathing them in liquid nitrogen
thank you there's also more long-term
challenges like minimalist which asks
you to complete the game using only a
pistol and a knife that sounds tough but
the game actually sets you up thanks to
another challenge destroying all 16
clockwork castallins this rewards you
with an indestructible knife an
invaluable tool to help complete
minimalist and that's when you notice
that all of these challenges and rewards
start to really Loop into one another
it's not just about doing one it's about
how completing one gives you a reward
that then makes the other one even
easier to complete and that's not the
only reward you can unlock there are a
host of bonus goodies that give real
incentive to do these challenges like
how about pairing that sweet pinstripe
suit with the Chicago sweeper Gane rank
on Hardcore congratulations Ashley has a
suit of armor so you uh you just you
don't need to worry about her anymore
she's fine the game has now rewarded you
for all your hard work by devolving into
some good old-fashioned video game
nonsense I mean for God's sakes they let
you buy the infinite rocket launcher on
New Game Plus surely the game has shown
you all it has to offer at this point or
has it
[Music]
Resident Evil 4 is the kind of game that
makes you want to try speed running and
what I mean by that is the game is
encouraging you to try to beat it as
fast as possible to master its mechanics
to become a true Resident Evil 4
connoisseur and it helps that the game
is built to be exploited in some really
really cool ways the most striking
example that has made the rounds is the
ability to skip the game's Infamous
opening Village by shooting the church
bell tower but it doesn't stop there as
this game is filled with little details
like this there's almost a if you can
imagine it the devs probably thought of
it type mentality here we all know the
rocket launcher is a great tool to
One-Shot bosses but what about
environmental obstacles
easy want to skip a padlock door well
just toss a well-placed grenade through
the window
same goes for this AA gun
or this wall during the wrecking ball
sequence
or how about a more game-breaking cheats
like placing a bunch of Mines where you
know a boss will spawn in
foreign
these are all really silly and a ton of
fun to do but they also serve a greater
purpose as an important tool for the
game's ultimate Challenge obtaining S
Plus rank on professional this
monstrosity requires you to play
professional on a brand new game meaning
no carrying over any weapons or upgrades
you need to complete it in under five
and a half hours and can only save 15
times which yeah is less than one save
per chapter accomplishing this run is no
small task requiring you to employ every
trick in the book to pull it off in a
way playing the game multiple times on
New Game Plus learning the encounters
and mastering the combat has prepared
you with the knowledge to succeed plus
completing those other challenges helps
as well because you get to bring in any
bonus rewards you unlocked such as
Ashley's Invincible armor the
unbreakable knife and the Chicago
sweeper which gets infinite ammo as its
exclusive upgrade meaning you can make
things a little easier on yourself
thank you it's still really hard Bo but
it's all worth it when hunting finally
bestows you with that coveted S Plus
you're rewarded with a sense of pride a
few other challenges and gaming can
bring but even more importantly you're
finally given those sweet sweet cat ears
went to the cat ears too again oh they
uh give you infinite ammo
whether intentional or not Resident Evil
4 is an incredible example of how
replaying a game can be just as if not
more rewarding than the first
playthrough the game incorporates player
Advantage into its gameplay loot letting
you bring your tools and knowledge with
you it's designed to be poked at and
broken embracing alternate strategies it
all feels incredibly considered and can
truly be appreciated and recognized with
multiple playthroughs Resident Evil 4 is
already an incredibly rewarding game on
one playthrough alone but it's all the
more impressive how it continues to
subvert players with each loop it's also
just incredibly cathartic to one shot
this with a rocket launcher to the face
or this
hey everyone thanks for watching this
first episode of no HUD we air new
episodes every Wednesday so if you
enjoyed this we hope to see you next
week but that's not all you have to look
forward to GameSpot is actually
launching a whole host of new shows such
as how it's saved where Dave Klein dives
into gaming history 3 and the game's
mascots and people that saved their
series from obscurity the first episode
is all about how the original Resident
Evil 4 brought much needed change to an
at the time declining franchise to
celebrate all these great new shows
we're actually doing a gosh dang
giveaway be sure to check out the pinned
comment below for info on how you can
win one of many prizes including
resident before remake Jedi Survivor or
even a PlayStation 5. available to us
residents only terms and conditions
apply
all right
Mary killed Leon Louise Ada uh oh okay
yeah
for sure I mean you know I'll marry Leon
yeah yeah yeah until uh I'll kill Lewis
yeah yeah I don't feel good about it no
I don't either but I mean I think I
think that's the right choice yeah
[Music]
how far could he have gone
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we got the chance to visit Capcom and
get hands on with the first few hours of
EXO Primal the upcoming multiplayer
action game that pits two teams against
each other as they compete to kill lots
and lots of dinosaurs so enjoy this
gameplay and remember EXO Primal comes
out on July 14th for PC PlayStation and
Xbox including day one game pass
there's a hole
[Music]
thank you
dinosaur called
you are completing objectives faster
than an enemy team
proceed to next mission
eating dinosaur color Mission
[Music]
please wait summoning Raptors
thank you
summoning tourettes
Summit rappers
[Music]
foreign
Follow The Watcher proceed to next
mission
initiating dinosaur College preparing
combat area please wait
nice work
[Applause]
dinosaur called
you are completely objective slower than
the enemy team
initiating area defense Mission
preparing combat area
and then the specified area go to the
area near the marker and begin defending
at the summit rappers
[Music]
some of the cyanonephosauruses
area defense problems 25 percent
some of the dilophosauruses
just
Ice
Area defense projects 50 percent
75 percent
area defense
thank you you are completely objective
slow than the enemy team
Follow The Watcher
proceed to next mission
[Music]
Summit Raptors
area defense Progressive
foreign
[Music]
Summit Raptors
area defense
nice work you are completing objectives
faster than the enemy you're not going
anywhere
bouncing back
good morning you will now commence the
final mission brace yourselves for
interdimensional travel prepared for
combat
warning the enemy team has entered this
dimension
you are at Great risk of being attacked
stay alert at all times
the final mission is coupling control
approach the Uplink and secure it then
initiate data transfer
maintain your proximity to an enemy
controlled Uplink to disable that Uplink
and claim it for your
job
Uplink a is taking damage defendant
defended
[Music]
foreign
defend it
a is taking damage Defenders
data transfer 50 complete
warning the enemy team has activated The
Dominoes
[Music]
prioritize its distruction
and attack the enemies
[Music]
um
has been lost
in 30 seconds
[Music]
thank you
hey everyone welcome to the Capcom
showcase pre-show I'm Andy this is Joe
from the Capcom USA Community team
before we get to the main show which I'm
really excited about hopefully you guys
are too we have a pre-show plan for you
yeah we got some pretty cool stuff we're
going to be doing an interview with one
of our developers over at Capcom Japan
we're going to be talking to one of our
voice talents who worked on Street
Fighter 6 and to get things started
we're going to be highlighting a Capcom
Creator who's done some pretty cool
Street Fighter 6 art in the past so
we're really excited about that so let's
go ahead and get that started
foreign
[Music]
look around
oh oh
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
clev is so talented clev if you're
watching thank you so much for doing
that time lapse for us yeah it's just
really cool how the art really tells a
story right you've got Kimberly but then
all the Legacy characters from Street
Fighter is just so cool to see and if
you really like that artwork we are
going to post that on our social media
channel so please check take a look at
that after the show and now we have an
interview with the voice of Luke from
Street Fighter 6 Alex Lee Alex how are
you I'm good man I'm happy to be here uh
before we get into talking about Luke
um how did you get into voice acting uh
I think it was one summer day I was
eating a bowl of noodles and I thought
to myself voice acting is cool maybe
I'll try that that's it
that's it that's where I went yeah did
the noodles also get you to the role of
Luke yeah I showed up to the studio and
I went and I said that's the guy uh but
no seriously how did you get the role of
Luke and like and like how did you
approach that whole performance when we
got the character like character slides
and everything I read through his
description is like his hobbies and I
was like this guy is kind of like me
pretty much that role was just me trying
to put myself out there and kind of
relaxing a little bit it was actually
one of the first roles where I got to
play somebody that was just like me
Luke's had a pretty interesting Journey
um you know he started at kind of the
tail end of Street Fighter 5 and now is
at the Forefront of Street Fighter VI
how did you approach the two
performances differently for five uh
they wanted something younger so Luke
had a bit more of an aggressive attitude
he was a lot more arrogant he was a lot
more cocky and he was just kind of like
this random Punk that showed up and was
like who wants to fight me so for six we
definitely kind of like mellowed down
he's got a job now wow amazing I guess
after getting beaten up all this time
he's like I'm gonna lay back a little
bit and figure out how to train myself
and actually hone my fighting style I
think it's it's been a really
interesting journey to see not only how
his characters have like evolved but
also the reception of that change as
well the this is the first Street
Fighter game that was recorded in
English first right and you were one of
the First characters to record your
lines what was the experience like and
how that changed things up for you for
me this was like a brand new way to do
this because what N5 is a dub so we have
to match the timing of the Japanese
voice line we have to match the Cadence
the tone and the animation so there's a
lot going on there's a lot that you have
to constantly be juggling but for six it
was a lot more loose it was more flow
and for the first time we got that sweet
mouth Tech where you can say anything
and the characters would you know
automatically lip sync so that was
really really cool and I just had a lot
more time a lot more freedom to deliver
lines how I wanted to do it and also
again because we were creating this
character in the US I got to put a lot
of my ideas in there as well so that was
that was a much much different process
than five So speaking of you putting
yourself into Luke and everything uh I
see online we all see online yes your
advocacy for Luke the memes everything
how much you love them where does that
come from and what's that whole
experience like I
never thought this day would come where
I would get to be in a Street Fighter
game for me it's more about how this is
a once in a lifetime opportunity and I
just got to make the best of it so you
know with my full heart I just was like
I'm gonna have fun with this character
actually some of my posts have even like
reached a wider Global audience they
have I visited the Capcom Japan office
and I met up with nakayama-san and the
whole team over there and I walked into
the studio and they were like we've all
seen your Twitter and I'm like no what
happened no and they're like no no it's
good we like it we like it and they
thanked me for uh you know promoting the
character and just having fun with him
and they wanted to use that energy and
put it into how they wrote and how they
made the character and I was I was
really honored by that people are
playing Street Fighter 6 now any
favorite lines that you want to oh let's
hear them yeah we got a lot of good ones
we obviously we got the sandblast but we
also got the gotta say you're pretty
photogenic that's the one everyone wants
to hear yeah that's that's a good one
hadouken there we go that one was fun
there's one where he whiffs his ultimate
and he goes yeah
yeah those are those are all like
like great lines I remember recording
because all the funniest lines we got
them in like one take and then they were
like that's it ship it I'm like you sure
they're like nope it was good I'm like I
messed up they're like that's you're
supposed to mess up it's Luke right he's
supposed to mess up he's gonna party
like that it's true it's true anything
you want to say to the community thank
you for your support over the last year
it's been amazing I've had such a blast
with this character uh interacting with
the community seeing all the memes
online seeing all the fan art it's been
so much fun and uh also thank you for
kicking my butt online that's awesome
too I love that part that's so cool
thanks guys uh no seriously though thank
you so much for everyone else at home
please stick around we have an interview
with localization director Andrew
Alfonso that we pre-recorded and that's
coming up right now
we're going to take you a little bit
behind the scenes today and we've got a
special guest to do that for us we're
with Andrew Alfonso coming to us all the
way from Osaka Japan uh he works over at
uh Capcom Japan so Andrew would you like
to introduce yourself yeah sure hey guys
uh so yeah I'm a localization director I
kept in Japan uh I've been a Capcom for
17 years now it's been quite a while uh
my first game that I worked on was uh
Mega Man Star Force for the DS after
that I worked on a bunch of Ace Attorney
games Ace attorneys three four five and
the specifications after that I worked
on the monster series for about 10 years
and now I'm back on the street fighter
series and yeah the latest game that I
worked on was Street Fighter 6 was which
was just released just an amazing tenure
over at Capcom but is there one in
particular a project that you've worked
on that's really near and dear to your
heart I would say the number one is
usually monster under four ultimates uh
that was kind of the first game that I
really got to work with with the dev
team very closely especially the
director's video okay sign into
buddhasan property number two is
definitely uh Street Fighter 6 because
just working with Nakia and
matsumoto-san has just been an absolute
pleasure uh their kind of philosophy on
how game development should work uh has
always been very appealing so I was
really happy to have this opportunity to
work with them on Street Fighter 6 level
working with them and they've been
amazing uh but before we get into like
Street Fighter six can you tell us a
little bit more about
localization the different
responsibilities and what it's all about
you know obviously we do you know
translation and text into the text and
whatnot uh but we also handle a lot of
the voice direction for games on top of
that we also get involved a lot in the
motion capture for the games um we also
do a lot of stuff just to help the dev
teams out uh in terms of like you know
diversity and you know culturalization
stuff like that I didn't remember that
you know not Kim wasan mentioned an
interview last time where we were uh he
was talking about you know Kimberly in
Street Fighter 6 and you know he you
know because he had a lot of Consultants
uh you know working with indicative
design just right he also talked to
Capcom employees and that's actually you
know the localization team that he came
to us and
um you know asked us for our feedback on
uh not only Kimberly but also you know
uh Lily and also DJ you know to make
sure that those characters are you know
in a good spot for fans and you know
they their designs are not only cool but
also you know something that is going to
be appealing to a worldwide audience
yeah tell us um you know how you're
involved in the game how you kind of got
started on the project I know it's
probably been a really long road for you
so just tell us about kind of your
experience yeah sure yeah it's been it's
been a very long time it's been about
three years at least for me I got
started off because uh Nike Amazon asked
me if I could help them out with the uh
with their prototyping he wanted to you
know get me in early because he knows
that I was a big fighting game fan I
know a lot of things that uh we should
try to improve for not only just fight
Street Fighter fans but also for a new
neuro audience that they're trying to
you know get with Street Fighter 6. he
brought me on uh mainly for that but
also because they're gonna be working on
this new commentary system that was
going to be a first for the series so
they asked me to come on early just to
you know get that sorted out so that we
could have something you know very
natural for you know the
English-speaking audience that are going
to use this commentary system so we're
definitely gonna hit on the real-time
commentary feature later but before that
what what were some of your goals as a
local localization director for Street
Fighter 6 and what do you hope fans Come
Away with in terms of the story
characters or just anything uh you know
one of the goals that I told the
director like Amazon this game has a
huge Legacy long Legacy uh we need to
give it the localization but it actually
deserves that we need to make sure that
this you know people Come Away with this
the better understanding of all the
characters and the characters that they
already love they fall in love with them
all over again the other goal that I had
was because I knew that we were going to
be working on world tour mode uh we had
stuff like the modern controls to appeal
to new users who are trying to aim for a
lot of new players to come in and we had
to make this uh as beginner friendly as
possible you know we're not going to be
throwing a lot of fgc community terms in
there we're gonna try to explain things
in a very natural but easy to understand
way
um and also like a lot of the for
example like a lot of the attack games
are still in Japanese and Terence uh
super uh super artists Street Fighter 5
is just completely in romaji they just
just transited from Japanese English
without actually translating it so no
one actually ever said the name of her
you know attack and I said this is kind
of this is not something that you want
you want something that people can kind
of attach to they get attached to the
name and you know especially with this
new commentary system we want people to
kind of call out these attack names so
that people get you know this certain
affinity for it and they start to like
get real attached to it and that's kind
of like the two basic goals two high
level goals that I had for this
localization tell us a little bit more
about the real-time commentary feature
like Amazon yeah when he approached me
about this uh I'll admit that I was very
uh very against the idea to be honest
with you because I just heard this I
just thought no we no we and it's it's
not because I thought the idea was bad I
just feel I just kind of like thought
about it for about a couple seconds and
I thought about the scope of this uh I
play a lot of sports games so I know
like how they do the commentary in those
games and they always you know spouse
about oh we recorded like 50 000 lines
from Monster to be only recorded uh 5
000 lines so going you know making that
huge jump in like line count is just you
know a huge mountain to scale so I was
kind of taking it back
um but you know I kind of settled down
and
um really go with you know the first
person we think people with was uh
Vicious he's just as in terms of as a
person he's just super reliable he's uh
you know has he has a good attitude
about everything he's very good on the
microphone he's always looking to
improve I kind of made him like okay he
like he's all these things because he's
kind of like the view of like
commentators and then you know if we're
gonna have a do as a commentator we need
a can counterpart
and you know there's no better
counterpart to Visions than KCC because
they work together on Street Fighter
League uh they actually work very well
together but they also have their just
completely contrasting Styles too um
which is very much you know he sounds
very professional uh even you know when
things get very excited in a match but
Casey does not do that he just goes he
goes nuts right and that's one of the
things that you know I really wanted for
these for these two choices yeah
definitely a lot uh involved in that
whole process especially with the
commentary system being a completely new
thing for a Street Fighter game speaking
of new things in Street Fighter 6 I do
want to ask you about
um the world tour mode and what it what
it's like just helping craft a story
mode for a Street Fighter game and also
a story mode where you can create your
own character what was that like what
was the experience like is there
anything
um that was really challenging or
memorable about the whole experience I
mean I think just the whole the main
challenging thing was just the scope of
the whole the whole mode is just
gigantic it's like a whole other game
onto itself like in terms of just like
how much we had to translate and forward
um this is actually bigger than a month
Monster Hunter game but a good margin so
it was uh you know very big in scope one
of the one of the things that was uh
really uh a pleasure to
hear was that the main scenario writer
was uh actually the the creator of the
Breath of Fire series he's also worked
on Dragon's Dogma as well so we kind of
had this confidence that okay this this
story is going to be it's gonna be good
it's going to be solid we're going to
have a good solid base to work on I
think the one challenge was having to
characterize so many new characters
returning characters so you don't really
know what their how they're supposed to
you know talk you know in terms of in
terms of hopefully flushed out
characters so we kind of have to
conceptualize that like on a basic level
to make sure that we're getting
something that's you know different from
all the other characters but also really
interesting and something fine it's
always incredible just hearing like all
the behind the scenes stuff about World
Tour and we we've talked a lot about
this but like some of my favorite things
that you guys did was the way like Ryu
texts you amazing hilarious uh but also
just like the tiny things you know how
like Lee Fen says like cha-chat to like
Chang Li just to keep that culture in
there it's it's fantastic so thank you
so much for like having so much of a
detail-oriented approach to World Tour
yeah thanks so much for joining us this
was this was awesome just to be able to
hear uh about all these behind the
scenes stuff uh in developing the game
uh any closing comments for uh the
street fighter and the Capcom fans out
there that are getting ready for the uh
the show the Showcase happening yeah I
mean you know Street Fighter 6 is out
there has been released uh you know
we're still working on the game as uh
you know as always
um I do want to hear you know if anyone
has any opinions about how the writing
is and how the voices are I I've always
been keeping track of that uh and again
Andrew thanks for joining us
um and to everybody for watching
all right that's gonna do it for our
pre-show thanks to everybody for joining
us and thanks to our guests Alex Andrew
and cleb for joining us for all these
segments it was really great to talk to
everybody and show off your content we
do want to mention there is going to be
a post show so please stick around for
that after the main show but you know
we're getting close uh Andy any word
parting words that you want to say yeah
if you guys have been paying attention
we've been wearing these Capcom hoodies
if you guys want one yourself go to the
Capcom Amazon store so with that we'll
see you guys later
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
if you decides to every story
foreign
[Music]
ready to die okay
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Mega Man Battle Network Legacy
Collection
[Music]
this is where my fellow Hunters
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the Capcom showcase
before we get started we'd like to share
the June 11th 2023 marked capcom's 40th
anniversary
a big thanks to everyone for playing our
games
it's thanks to our amazing fans that we
can celebrate such a milestone
we look forward to creating many more
games in the years to come and we hope
that you'll continue to enjoy them
[Music]
now it's time to show off our latest
titles at the Capcom showcase
until the end so you don't miss anything
this video
[Music]
thank you
foreign
traditional Japanese Aesthetics come to
life through the power of re engine
experience a unique blend of strategy
and action in this epic Tale
a beautiful yet unsettling world of
mystery awaits in
kunitsugami path of the goddess
coming to Xbox series X Xbox series S
Windows PlayStation 5 and steam
Mega Man X dive offline is coming to
steam IOS and Android
[Music]
the Deep walk which holds collected
memories of the Mega Man X Series is
under attack
dive into cyberspace using Hunter
programs to recover data before it's too
late
play as Mega Man X and other characters
from the Mega Man franchise
including characters that haven't been
playable before
[Music]
foreign
level up your favorite characters and
equipment to create a powerful Hunter
[Music]
power up your weapons and more to
customize your character however you
want
[Music]
Mega Man X dive offline
control and develop over 100 different
characters
play as a variety of characters
including new Heroes created for Mega
Man X dive
complete stages and use element metals
to recover memory pieces then analyze
recovered memories to unlock characters
[Music]
there are more than 900 stages to play
challenging mechanics and enemies await
on classic and new stages
you're bound to clash with familiar
bosses from the past
build the ultimate Hunter and save the
Deep log from total Destruction
[Music]
[Applause]
Mega Man X dive offline launches in 2023
[Music]
now here's the Capcom Spotlight corner
a new era of fighting games is upon us
Street Fighter 6 launched on June 2nd
it's already received an enthusiastic
welcome from fighting game fans around
the world
Street Fighter 6 includes World Tour an
expansive single-player story mode
fighting ground the core fighting game
experience made even more accessible
and battle Hub a social space where
players from around the world can
compete and hang out
these are the game's three main modes
in addition we're planning to release
new Fighters and content so you can
enjoy the game for a long time to come
fighter 6 is out now for PlayStation 5
PlayStation 4 Xbox series X Xbox series
s and steam don't miss it
[Music]
foreign
we also have an announcement for Capcom
Pro Tour 2023 this year's Capcom Pro
Tool will feature Street Fighter 6 the
newest entry in the series
players from around the world will
compete in Regional matches and battle
to be this year's champion
to celebrate the launch of Street
Fighter 6 this year we have our largest
prize pool ever the total prize pool for
Capcom pro tool is over 2 million
dollars with one million dollars going
to first place
Capcom Pro Tour 2023 will feature three
types of tournaments
online premiers offline premiers and
World Warrior
[Music]
the winners of each tournament will
advance to the World Finals at Capcom
cup 10.
stay tuned to see which player will
crush the competition and take home this
year's championship
next we have news about Street Fighter
League Pro JP 2023
in Street Fighter week the world's top
players form teams of four and compete
in official Capcom Team league matches
we have the largest number of teams ever
The Opening match will be held on July
7th
and will be streamed live on the Capcom
Fighters JP Channel on YouTube and
twitch
don't forget about the street fighter
League World Championship 2023
determine the teams that will go on to
compete in the World Championship
get up close and personal with Resident
Evil 4 on Playstation 5. the game's main
story will be playable in VR with
PlayStation VR2
thanks to the power of PlayStation VR2
you'll be able to experience an even
more immersive version of the game
Take Aim as you fight to survive
re4's cutting edge knife action is a
core part of the game and the
PlayStation VR2 sense controller makes
pairing even more intuitive
experience Extreme Survival horror first
hand
Resident Evil 4 VR mode is a free DLC
exclusive to PlayStation VR 2.
now on to the next game in today's
lineup
[Music]
sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
here's the latest on the game
[Applause]
hello everyone I'm Ashira takumi the
original creator of ghostric
it's almost time for the games to
release and I can't wait for you to play
it but first let's get started with this
foreign
[Music]
his own murder he will meet and change
the lives of all sorts of people in all
sorts of situations
fix machine and related at first but
each person plays a vital role in
today's story and together their stories
will lead him the wrong ultimate truth
so think of the demo as a doorway
inviting you into a great big mystery
it's been 30 years since we made the
original game and just like season I met
many new people and there were many
miracles that occurred during each
development
I have no doubts these experience is a
wood-shaped go Street into Unforgettable
gamers
to the team developing it for the
discount at all the fans have shown so
much love towards it answer great food
to all of you
and feed that through these ribbons
ghostrick will be available to so many
more people around the world
now to wait for its release
and one more thing I put this very very
hot for two weeks for this appearance
is something it will make me very happy
if it could speak in Japanese
[Music]
from the creator of the Ace Attorney
series Shu takumi this classic mystery
game is being reborn
one night a man named Sissel loses both
his memory and his life using the powers
of the dead he tries to solve the
mystery of his own death the only clue
he has is a red-headed detective a
knight of Mystery Begins anew
a rookie detective brimming with a sense
of justice
she too is being targeted and Cecil
witnesses her death
who was I
why was I killed
who killed me
but what does it mean that I was given
these powers of the Dead
powers of the Dead to possess and trick
items the controls are Easy Connect
sissel's glowing blue soul to the core
of objects to possess them
possess the tire
possess the bowl possess the star
ornament you can then trick the objects
you possess trick the guitar to play it
what will happen when you trick the cart
trip the door to open it
possessing and tricking objects will let
you access new areas
Sizzle can go back four minutes before
someone's death
what happened before her murder
those Clues are hidden in the past
follow past events in real time
the limit however is four minutes
help people avoid near-death
predicaments and change their face
Sissel will face death in many forms
changing their face will change the
story
[Music]
and that story must be linked in some
way to the mystery of sissel's death
Ghost Trick launching on June 30th 2023
demo version available now don't miss
the pre-order bonuses
the official website for details
now on to the next game in today's
lineup
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
players serve as lawyers for the falsely
accused
Battle For Justice in the courtroom and
uncover the truth
now the fourth fifth and sixth Mainline
Ace Attorney games are being brought
together
to share the story of Apollo Justice and
his allies in the Dark Age of the law
on Nintendo switch PlayStation 4 Xbox
One windows and steam
the colorful characters and courtroom
drama of each game have been relitigated
in beautiful full HD available in seven
languages Japanese English French
German
Korean and traditional and simplified
Chinese
we've also added voice recordings for
the new languages
we're sure there's no objection to
everything included in this collection
Apollo Justice Ace Attorney Trilogy is
currently in development for release in
early 2024
please look forward to more information
about this collection in the future
next we have some Capcom news to share
this month marks capcom's 40th
anniversary
as part of the celebration we've opened
a digital theme park called Capcom town
[Music]
take a stroll through the museum to view
original artwork and other materials
from various titles on display
you can even play a few of capcom's
beloved Classics for free
[Music]
head on over to the castle to cast your
vote in the Capcom elections
[Music]
participants will receive a special
reward so don't miss out
we can't wait for everyone to enjoy
these attractions
[Music]
along with the many other fun
experiences we've prepared at
thank you
a Capcom ID account is required to play
Resident Evil reverse
our new upcoming title exoprimal
and to use the online features of Street
Fighter 6.
[Music]
you can also use this account with other
Capcom services and campaigns such as a
survey about today's Capcom showcase
we'll release more titles and services
compatible with Capcom ID soon
register now for Capcom ID
now for the latest on EXO Primal ahead
of next month's launch
hello everyone I'm takudo hidoka the
director of EXO primal
I'm excited to share the latest EXO
Primal news with you all but first let's
check out this video
hello
my name is
basically the IPS Godfather he was
responsible for the entire exosuit
project you know anchor Division I
assume
EXO suits were developed right here
it's our only shot we need access to the
Past online r d is just waiting to be
picked up back in 2040. intact and hot
on the present the access codes to
override Leviathan you can shut it down
Heisel the fuel of the future all this
time Heisel is a side effect of time
travel did they just
out of dead dinosaurs
at least we know why dinosaurs bleed
blood
unrefined low Zone in the blood
I mean look at this it's a walking Vlog
stuff
[Music]
thank you
let me see this we'll find a way out of
here
all anchor project files have serial
numbers look for anything starting with
one eight one that's the project code
for the buying its core okay duck oh
I didn't get your name
Bahama Higgs
well done you fought desperately and
survived the perfect exosuit development
project is nearing fruition activating
Massacre module summoning Neo T-Rex form
this is all helping to make a better exo
suit
excited combat project The Savage
gauntlet
foreign
what did you think
that was a lot of new info before we
dive in I'd like to give a huge thanks
to all the players who participated in
the open beta test back in March
we were extremely pleased to have so
many participants plus you gave us a lot
of invaluable feedback
we can't thank you enough
while only portions of the dyno survival
content were made available for the open
beta test today we'll be introducing
more content included in the full game
let's take a look at what you can expect
when EXO Primal Launches on July 14th
[Music]
let's start with the story Ace the
game's protagonist is transported to the
year 2040 and forced to participate in a
never-ending series of War Games the
story unfolds as you play through Dino
survival the game's main mode Gathering
Intel to update the analysis map
unravels the Mysteries surrounding
parallel worlds and the AI entity known
as Leviathan at times players will also
engage in special boss battles as part
of the main story
Dino survival mode will also change as
the story progresses
you'll unlock new missions with a
variety of objectives including 10
player co-op a multitude of dinosaurs to
fight and more maps
the game will also feature an assortment
of unlockables and challenges
modules can be used to enhance exosuits
and modify active skills
these modules can be obtained by
fulfilling certain conditions while you
play the game
you can also personalize your appearance
with a variety of Cosmetics such as
exosuit skins weapon skins decals and
emotes
the game also features a special
five-player mission that changes weekly
with squads from around the world for
the fastest completion times or by
earning Awards through achievements like
most damage block with a tank suit in
Battle
there are many ways to enjoy the game
even after completing the main story
we took your feedback into consideration
as well
in the full version of EXO Primal we
plan to implement a mode where Victory
is determined by completing missions as
quickly as possible instead of direct
combat with other players we hope you
look forward to that
now let's go over all the new info we
just saw in the video
[Music]
who was that new face at the beginning
meet Dr signs the developer of the
exosuits
and the head of anchor division ibs's
Elite research group based on bikitoa
Island
the strativator a space elevator that
extends from the anchor division
research facility into orbit will also
be a playable map
incredible battles will unfold while EXO
Fighters and dinosaurs Clash atop this
massive space elevator
players will even encounter dangerous
mutations of dinosaurs known as
neosource the most deadly among them
being the Neo T-Rex
you'll need to work together with your
team to stand a chance at taking them
down
oh no is that a swarm of Neo T-Rexes
water leviathan's true intentions
wait what's the deal with this new
exosuit
while it may look similar to Deadeye
this exosuit is a variant called Deadeye
Alpha burst fire
unlike the default Deadeye this variant
comes equipped with a weapon that can
burst fire or be used as a shotgun
allowing EXO fighters to change their
style of play
exosuit variants including Deadeye Alpha
will be added in a title update
following the full version's release
at the end of the video we revealed
Savage Gauntlet a mode that lets you
take on special five-player missions
that change weekly
in this mode players can enjoy a change
of pace from Dino Survival by competing
against EXO fighters from all over the
world for the fastest completion times
more info about exosuit variants and
Savage Gauntlet will be revealed at the
Xbox games showcase extended
be sure to tune in
and last but not least
we're excited to announce that we'll be
holding a second open beta test
this time we're including additional
Story related missions
10 player co-op missions
and other adjustments based on
everyone's feedback
check out the official website for dates
and times
we hope you're all excited to try out
this new content
players will also receive a new reward
for participating don't miss out
we'll continue to make adjustments to
exoprimal leading up to the game's
launch on July 14th
thank you again for all the feedback
we look forward to seeing you in the
second open beta test
that's all we have for you today
see you in the war games it's going to
be a ton of fun
foreign
next up is the last title we'll be
showing off today
[Music]
hi everyone my name is hideyaki itsuno
and I'm the director of Dragon's Dogma
2. it's been over a year since we
celebrated 10 years of Dragon's Dogma
and I can finally give you some more
information about the new game first
let's take a look at the trailer we
revealed the other day
[Music]
thank you
then have we forgotten that you've
protected me from the dragon's flames
you need only believe in your own
destiny there is a force that begs the
question if he's a mere Mama then where
might our true and recent Empress
Nadine's life is in your hands sir
praise be for only the sovereign
[Music]
foreign
what did you think
the action RPG game Dragon's Dogma was
released in 2012. now a decade later I'm
proud to share a look at the highly
anticipated sequel Dragon's Dogma 2.
today I want to talk about two
characteristics that Dragon's Dogma 2
will inherit from its predecessor
first Dragon's Dogma 2 will be a single
player game but with pawns at your side
it will feel like Co-op and second
gameplay will feature action
role-playing mechanics set in an open
world environment in the Dragon's Dogma
series you embark on your adventures
with pawns other worldly beings
controlled by AI alongside the
player-controlled Arisen you can embark
on your journey with the main Pawn that
can be customized to your liking
as well as up to two additional support
pawns you can borrow from other players
to form a party of up to four characters
pawns are controlled by the AI and are
now capable of even more precise
decisions than in the previous title
helping you in
they can also help guide you to new
locations
core give you a high five following a
successful battle it really feels like
playing in a party with other players
Dragon's Dogma 2 is built with the re
engine resulting in a dense World woven
with high graphical Fidelity you'll
enjoy a world roughly four times the
size of the original Dragon's Dogma with
more to experience than ever before the
characters and monsters that populate
the world are given life thanks to the
power of AI and players will feel like
they've been reborn in this vibrant
fantasy world you can look forward to a
variety of vocations to choose from your
vocation will shape your arisen's role
throughout the adventure will you take
on enemies with swords magic it's all up
to you we'll have much more to share in
the future but for now
I want to go over a few sections from
the trailer that show what we've
improved for Dragon's Dogma 2.
this game is designed to enable players
to take on situations in their own way
in addition to AI advanced technology
like immersive physics brings pawns
monsters and NPCs to life
what would happen if you destroyed that
bridge or if you pulled that Monster's
leg
what other exciting possibilities can
you think of
meet two characters pivotal to the story
that also appear in the game's key art
urika a bow wielder with a deep
connection to the erisic and nadenia a
high priestess of the B string which
appear in the series for the first time
what Destiny awaits how will they affect
your fate the intricate relationships
and situations you will encounter in the
game are sure to keep you on your toes
[Music]
during your adventure you will come
across familiar monsters from the
previous game as well as new monsters
such as Medusa you can look forward to
new player vocations and many new
experiences unique to Dragon's Dogma 2.
please stay tuned for more information
thank you so much for tuning in
[Music]
Dragon's Dogma 2 will be available on
PlayStation 5 Xbox series X Xbox series
s and steam
and now a quick look at the Capcom 40th
anniversary sale
we have well-known titles such as
Dragon's Dogma and the Ace Attorney
series
don't miss this opportunity to pick up a
few of capcom's most influential hits at
some great prices
to celebrate we're also offering a
limited time bundle of some of capcom's
major titles on Steam
that wraps up today's Capcom showcase
thank you for watching we're always
working on new games and updates and we
hope you're as excited as we are for
capcom's 40th anniversary
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to the Capcom
showcase post show I'm Andy I'm on the
community team at Capcom and with me
today we have Joe also from the
community team and we have Nico Nico do
you want to introduce yourself uh hey
there I'm Nico B I'm a Capcom Creator as
well as a Creator over on YouTube and
twitch and uh I'm really happy to be
here guys thanks for having me thanks
for joining us yeah so we just got done
with the Capcom showcase what was
everyone's favorite part in the chat let
us know I think mine has to be EXO
Primal I love changing the rigs I love
just seeing which wig goes into like
which situation and everything and I'm a
big dinosaur fan so how about you Joe
yeah it's shaping up well so much good
stuff in there Dragon's Dogma 2 for me
it's been very near dear to my heart
super excited for it but yeah lots of
good stuff how about you Nico oh
absolutely it has to be Ace Attorney I'm
so thrilled to see uh Apollo coming back
he's my boy uh absolutely thrilled to uh
to see that collection come back um and
yeah that's what leads us actually into
uh what we're gonna be checking out here
uh is actually done by by the same
creator of Ace Attorney and that is a
ghost Rick a phantom detective for those
of you who don't know Ghost Trick is
coming out on June 30th on PS4 Xbox
Steam and switch it's a puzzle game a
lot of cool puzzles it's very narrative
heavy and you're basically Sissel the
main character is trying to find out
what happened to him why why am I dead
is what he basically asks himself and he
got to figure out through different
scenarios it's really cool and we're
actually going to do something for you
right now Joe what are we gonna do yeah
so in this showcase we just announced
that the demo for this game is live on
all the platforms that Andy mentioned so
we're going to take you through that
demo um they are there are two chapters
in this demo really from the start of
the game you can get familiar with the
characters the game mechanics just get a
general sense of the vibe of it and that
brings us to what we're doing today is
walking us through it and you know we
couldn't ask for a better person to join
us and that's that's Nico's oh heck yeah
I hopefully I can still remember uh how
to do this so
um let's get into it all right let's
check it out
maybe we should set the stage for what
we're seeing right obviously we're
seeing
a Pomeranian right there in the center
who unfortunately is not moving at all
very tragic we've got it a strange
person that's wandering around this
apartment
um just overall just a really mysterious
situation
this is how all the scenarios kind of
start pretty much the one before this if
you do play the demo chapter one Stars
Lin and you're trying to save her and
now you're in this situation where
you're trying to figure out first what's
going on like what's what's the scene
what's happening right now and then you
have to go into the puzzle and it's to
figure out why the I'm not going to say
his name but why the dog there is uh on
his back yeah Nico who are we playing as
in this uh so this we're uh playing as
uh Sissel uh about this point he's
already gotten at least a decent grasp
on his uh Ghost Trick abilities
um and he's already uh averted one fate
uh and while we're here we're going to
uh go over here and check on our little
friend down here
right now our friend is just a blue blue
flame or blue blob he's not he's not
quite sure uh what what their form is
supposed to be and every in every ghost
that shows up in this game when you
first meet them they always they always
come out in this form they especially
have to be reminded about who they are
they are dead so yeah yeah you have to
figure it out
I put two
but let's hope we never find that that's
right
no no no I don't want to find that out
so you're talking to who you think is a
dog or you believe believe to be the dog
there
was to be fair this character
uh no joke was always my personal
favorite when I played this game
yeah this the energy of this little dude
that's the little guy there he is I gave
him this forgive me for this but there's
no time to lose Miss Cabela my best
trouble
I think that's exactly how we would
sound yeah
if you could talk that's right there
yeah he was uh he's so funny yes this is
this is missile the purebred pure
blooded Pomeranian you make sure that
you know that every time right there
yeah
every time we post him on like a socials
everyone's like crazy yeah everyone just
screams a missile yep the cool thing
about bringing this game back is I'm
sure there's going to be a whole new
generation of people naming their dog's
missile oh oh yes there's actually I
believe also missile in Ace Attorney as
well so uh clearly the team is is uh
partial to uh the name
um but yes this little dog he's he shows
up quite a few times throughout the game
and he's just your best little buddy
yes we're gonna let this scenario play
out and this is basically how did
missile die right essentially four
minutes ago we're going back in time so
let's do it
so you basically were winding back to
try and prevent what happened
pretty much yeah you're trying to go
back and see exactly what led to what
happened and then from there uh try to
undo the events and uh avert the
negative fate
while working with the dog while working
with the dog yes okay dog is
surprisingly sharp in this game so he he
does his best all right and he
definitely loves uh his owner Miss
Camilla all right he's he's very
passionate about keeping her safe at all
times with this version there's like
updated Graphics updated frame rate uh
there's one's Camilla is out there and
it's it looks it looks so smooth yeah it
does it's I can already tell the the
improved frame rate and also the
portraits look way sharper now yeah it
looks gorgeous really feels like a fully
realized version of that art sale that
they're trying to hit
um it just yeah it just looks so clean
the signature
I think the other thing about you know
games by shootikumi and the team is even
though they're very text Heavy
they they feel like the dialogue just
flows quickly right it has like impact
like you can you can hear the voices for
yourself
so what's going on right now
so we got this little girl she's looking
after her doggy the doggie loves to bark
at
everything and anyone who owns a
Pomeranian will know this is very true
our neighbor here with a big big glass
he's got the big glass yeah and you're
paying attention to everything that's
going on because it all kind of comes
together yeah I think the nice thing
about the scenario too is as you're
working through it multiple times like
there's dialogue that you can skip
through or you know it's just optional
if you want that spot back up for the
extra hints yeah exactly the nice thing
is you will be able to actually like
talk with your uh your party essentially
or uh Sissel will think things to
himself which will help give you a clue
in the right direction and when you
watch these scenes they're kind of
almost
in a way
giving you a hint as to the next
scenario right exactly yeah
there we go you see something something
like that and you think that seems
interesting
you're not already you have an idea like
piece together what it is that the game
is expecting you to do in each moment
a game that you have to focus on every
single thing that's happening
narratively at first before you actually
get into the puzzle element which I
guess is gonna happen after this but um
like right now like oh God there's
there's a mouse yeah what's gonna happen
with that
and then Powell missile react to that
and then it moves over to the neighbor
kind of just have to have everything in
your mind all at once to just uh
see what you're gonna do next
blue assassin man no
oh my God he looks Stern uh you really
like it when these jobs are outside the
original scum crop up yeah I mean you
can kind of feel like he's got this real
I don't know like intense Hitman yeah I
have to put it down as a separate charge
accounting never likes that but I guess
it can't be out sorry kid it's putting a
good at the birthday nothing personal
who would do that who would do that to a
little pomeranian doggy come on we don't
like that we don't like that no we gonna
We gotta change things look at that I'm
dead no I'm dead
and yet the dog still looks so happy
he's still so uh he's still so full of
energy watch his own death I know
welcome he can't he can't help him he
can't help he can't help it
no we this will not stand
we will not let this blue man get away
with it
and they're talking about uh Camilla's
headphones or sorry uh yeah Camila
Cabello's headphones yeah and they just
seem to be like the greatest headphones
yeah apparently they have amazing noise
canceling so good she didn't even hear
The Gunshot seriously
she's still reading her book too
so uh clearly the first thing we got to
do is uh try to figure out a way to uh
get this headphones off her head yeah
all right trick time
yeah so kind of the core core gameplay
mechanics right you can use the trick
ability to manipulate different objects
right that's right so you can when you
uh when you get into the game here if
you enter the ghost mode it actually
pauses everything but in regular uh uh
regular form here uh it essentially will
continue to play like a movie
um you also will occasionally get uh
little tips uh from your pals here or
you'll hear what uh sissel's thoughts
are to help sort of give you a clear
idea of what your like main objective is
um and it's good because there
definitely some moments where things are
like we're early on so a lot of what
we're going to be doing here is pretty
like it's I think self-explanatory but
they definitely get times moments later
on where you're you're definitely going
to need maybe a little bit of extra help
to sort of get you to where you need to
go but
um you can mess around with the
environment
um usually just manipulate it in small
ways like pushing the door here
um
so you can get an umbrella up here
yeah so we hate these headphones right
we need to get rid of them yeah so we
got to figure out some way to get them
down
but yeah it's like if we could just
knock them right into that little fish
tank that would probably
uh destroy them I imagine unless they're
like waterproof headphones those do
exist that's true those actually do
exist
so when you get the timing right on this
then right yeah so you got to wait for
the right moment here
you can also look around the environment
here too so all this is going to be
coming into play a little bit later yeah
but I think I just see a good moment
when uh
Camilla was grabbing her headphones
which is sort of seemingly kind of
fumbled around a bit so I think if I
just maybe wait a bit
yeah there we go
into the tank right into the tank the
frame perfect yeah very perfect press
oh man just bought those headphones the
headphones for a thousand dollars
she's gonna blame missile
that's right
uh ever the faithful little buddy
but the very least we bought ourselves
some time right at least you'll hear the
guy come in I mean that's not really
gonna solve you know her getting
kidnapped still a little bit more work
to do yeah so uh we're definitely gonna
have a little bit more currently we
don't have really a lot of room to move
but
um
so we got oh there we go and that should
roll the donuts over we actually have a
thing we can mess with here yeah so the
donuts are going to be really important
right I mean yeah the cart and its
placement is really important and looks
like she's kind of picking through that
insanely big stash of donuts hopefully
she doesn't notice that it uh moves
there and oh okay it's just I guess it
must be a must be a slant in the room
there
she just kind of rolls with it but you
also moved it right yeah yeah of course
I don't know if that happened to me I'd
be perfect
but then I'd be like no like no the dog
did it yeah
it had to beat the dog
um but yeah but doing that actually
allows us to reach other areas of the
room which and we can you know discover
things by interacting with them here so
like you can do this
which just further infuriates our
neighbor
uh oh we did do something though we
knocked a little uh a little thing down
and again you can sort of like continue
to get like updates and hints and ideas
from uh
uh your group here the sunny missile
says I'm truly embarrassed by my own
behavior
yeah he but he's he's graduating he's
graduated from Beyond the balls to to
barking at uh uh people and sounds in
stone all right yeah
um so here we can see too that like
there are moments where you really do
have to time things it's just like the
umbrella so like we need to be able to
like get up here which allows us to uh
get over to this section there's also
you see there's a spot above it too
yeah it looks like you can manipulate
that yeah and that speeds it up a bit
Camilla does not seem to care much about
it uh that's all this yeah
she's Studio she's reading her book you
know she's like I don't wanna I don't
want to do with anything my house is
possessed you know I don't know if it
was the headphones fault yeah actually
yeah I think it's the book yeah
something's going on with that book
uh we're gonna drop this there's a
little music box up there uh
I can't seem to actually manipulate
anyway but it it's there it's it's there
for some purpose uh we can hop back down
here again
uh
I think if we slow down we can actually
hop back down to some of these subjects
to
so we got a picture here we can
you can rock a book
okay so sometimes you kind of just have
to it's a little bit of trial and error
where you got to see like what
specifically can I do with this object
sometimes you can't do things like the
floor lamp I can't we can't seem to do
anything with
you just have to figure out with every
single thing like let's go here yeah
around around it can I manipulate and
see like how like how it is going to
form the overall puzzle pretty much okay
so by doing that we flip the ball uh but
as missile told us he doesn't care about
he doesn't care about the ball
unfortunately yeah
yeah I feel like if we could get
we can actually get the dog underneath
the couch in some way or do something to
get the girl underneath the couch to
actually like then she would be sort of
out of sight from the guy that breaks in
there
um so what else are we not messing
around with we got the donuts too
okay I went over to this side instead
oh it's a lit no it's a little pink rat
this time there's a there's a there's a
male Rattlers on the right and then a
little a little cute little uh little uh
Pink Rattlers on the opposite side
yeah missile is over there and he's
barking at it he doesn't like that rat
either
uh oh God I'm about to flick this little
rat around
oh God it deserved it it deserves it I'm
trying to steal that donut
also what is going on with this
apartment where they got rats just oh
yeah all right and Camilla's like
yeah I can afford the headphones but
it's a rap problem man yeah apparently
not cleaning
oh but this did distract her she did to
distract her and then and then
just in the nick of time sir it's our
boy it's our boy
oh he's here huh
he just he just Parks himself right
there
might as well make myself comfortable
while they even have a bowl of donuts
just for me how dare he how dare you
and just like that a Fate has been
averted
she's still caught up in a ball and
shaking with beer
love your missile voice oh thank you
thank you yes
honed over many years
um but yes we did it and with that I
mean he lived and fortunately she seems
to be uh keeping missile from uh you
know
barking and welcoming the murderous
assassin into their apartment
hope you did it you helped missile out
we did we saved him we saved our little
buddy that was actually the important
part Camila wasn't you know you know
true it's true it was really more about
the dog yeah at least to me yeah the
game's over we did it we did it we did
all right so this is kind of like where
they just pow wow at the end yeah yeah
essentially uh uh sort of explain what
his powers are
um and uh
because there are specific like uses for
it where you can use it and how you can
change and affect the world around you
um and that's sort of what uh sort of
pushes the game's narrative is the is
your limitations like a lot of stuff
later on I remember is where you really
start to uh mess with the environment in
ways that like sort of set us up almost
like a Rube Goldberg like Contraption uh
that you use to uh avert uh characters
face and uh uh essentially get the
outcome that you want yeah it's really
clever it's such a such a clever uh
system really it's not something I've
seen in any other game
yeah I think I think like a lot of you
know games by shoot to Kumi this the way
they kind of evolved those core
mechanics over time to get more and more
complex and you know this it gets more
challenging too right there's just more
ways to absolutely oh yeah and and truly
and the thing that I I really that
always gets me about these games and I
love seeing them you know all these
characters here now in like beautiful
high definition but it's just the the
character or the the charm that every
one of these characters uh like has in
every all these scenes you know that
everyone has like something about them
that makes them stand out and makes them
unique yeah um so that's something I've
just always loved about about his his
and his team's games
and you know now that we've solved uh
the mystery of missile's death I think
we can call it there and let's kind of
discover the rest for themselves I think
the entire team is just excited for
everyone to check this out uh you saw a
little bit of the demo here you can play
the demo now just the first two chapters
but the it's it's a upgraded version of
the game there's a better frame rate
improved Graphics smoother Graphics
there's like newly arranged uh
background music which we've been
listening to uh but yeah it comes out on
June 30th uh PS4 Xbox PC and Nintendo
switch I hope you guys check it out just
super excited for a new generation of of
players and and you know returning
players to come back to this they get to
play on the big screen or you can play
it on your switch where you can take it
on the go so
um yeah just just uh gonna be really
excited to see some of the reactions to
people discovering it for the first time
or coming back to it so check out this
game this game there's nothing quite
like the experience that you get from
this uh it's such a Charming Story full
with just such lovable characters I I
can guarantee that you will come to the
end really enjoying the experience that
you had so but uh yeah guys thank you so
much for having me I'm so glad to join
you for this thanks for joining us we
really appreciate it uh yeah before that
if you guys want a pre-order go strict
now you can get four different
backgrounds and two different background
music tracks I think that's I think
that's it for us right yeah all right
well thank you for coming hope you
enjoyed Ghost Trick demo download it
right now and we will see you next time
foreign
[Music]